hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu vlogmas
Tag 7 heute haben wir es geschafft eine
Woche schon gewblloggt und wir sind
ziemlich am Arsch timo hat heute einfach
so 8 Stunden den Blog von gestern
geschnitten und wir wollten heute schon
zeitziegen Tour machen wir verschieben
das jetzt auf morgen morgen ist aber ein
total crazy Feiertag hier in Mailand
oder in Italien allgemein ich bin mir
gerade nicht so sicher mit der Kultur
egal ich habe dann einfach mal in einem
italienischen Supermarkt nach
Süßigkeiten gesucht und in dem in dem
ich war waren tatsächlich nicht so viel
also wir sind hier so sehr im Zentrum
dass hier gar nicht so ein wirklicher
Supermarkt ist also ein größerer was ich
aber gefunden
habe kinderini wie cool sehen diese
kinderinis bitte aus ja und was machen
wir heute und erstmal die
Kinder wie wir uns vlogmas vorgestellt
haben wie vogm
läuft ja das ist so ein
Keks lecker m mega gut dann noch von
Kinder plumcake habe ich noch nie
gesehen sie hatten auch noch mit
griechischem Joghurt etwas ich habe mal
so ein bisschen im Supermarkt rumgefilmt
sieht am Ende aus wie normaler
Supermarkt also es hat mich jetzt nichts
überrascht die Produkte sahen alle schon
so ein bisschen anders aus aber ja
preparato Joghurt aller
greka kleines
tötchen Alkohol schmeckt wirklich nach
Alkohol also das würde ich meinem Kind
jetzt nicht so gerne geben und Nummer D
das war einfach etwas aus Gummi was ich
nicht kannte
was total umständlich verpackt ist wie
heißt das Go lidor goleado sieht ja auch
aus wie so ein to go Süßigkeit dein
hartes Haribo weiß nicht was das sein
soll es ist so hart das schmeckt wie als
ob im Haribo eine Woche draußen lag na
ja das sind italienische Süßigkeiten und
heute gehen wir aber noch mal shoppen
mailand ist nämlich eine sehr
weihnachtliche Stadt Sie dekorieren sehr
schön ich meine mit den alten Gebäuden
das sieht einfach total toll aus und es
ist auch die Stadt der Mode des Designs
des Konsums und das wollen wir heute
auch mal noch ein bisschen austesten wir
waren ja schon gestern ein Badanzug
kaufen aber konnten nicht so wirklich
mal so richtig shoppen Leute es ist 18
Uhr und wir verlassen zum ersten Mal
geistkrank das Hotelzimmer der Vlog
heute hat wirklich viel zu lange Zeit
gebraucht und wir müssen echt gucken wie
es die nächsten Tage kürzer hinbekommen
weil so können wir nicht weßar warum das
so langeeduert hat war Ire so einfach
ewig gezogen alles ja weil wir halt auch
den ganzen Tag mitfilmen deswegen die
nächsten Folgen wir hoffen wir kriegen
einfach ein Thema hin und wir zeigen
euch ein Thema eine Sache die wir machen
und dann muss es gut sein ich ich kann
wir können auch nicht schon an Tag 7
aufgeben auf kein Fall war ein kleiner
bup in Road aber fahren
weiter und ich haben euch ja schon
gezeigt dass wir uns aus jedem Land in
dem wir sind chrisbaumkugel mitnehmen
und jetzt sind wir gerade an einem Laden
vorbeigelaufen der hat einfach die
hübschesten
Design mäßigsten Christbaumkugeln die
ich jemals gesehen habe und ich glaube
wir müssen uns jetzt eine aussuchen ne
die ist heftig guck mal kleine das ist
heftig ich finde aber auch die ist
heftig das Ei ist
heftig wie findest du cool ja wie den
kleinen aber du weiß jeder darf sich
eine aussuchen mal der
ist der süß ja mal so für 1200 € so ein
Elefanten ich habe mich gerade daran
erinnert dass wir von der Tante von Timo
eine Schale bekommen haben und sie hat
uns gesagt ach das ist italienisches
Design das ist von Alessi und die ist so
toll und und wir kennen halt den Namen
nicht also s war eine schöne Schale aber
wir kennen halt Alessi nicht und
jetzt ja jetzt kennen wir alessie jetzt
kennen wir also Tante Sigi jetzt bitte
nicht mehr zugucken weil es könnte sein
dass du was von hier zu Weihnachten
bekommst meine Laune ist schlagartig
besser geworden wir haben eine krbaum
Kugel gekauft aber wir lassen sie zu uns
nach Hause schicken das ist einfach
einfacher weil wir noch unterwegs sein
werden und das war jetzt auch gar kein
Stress für den ne ne war super
entspannend das ist so weihnachtlich ich
bleib
aus Mailand ist eine Weihnachtsstadt ich
hätte nicht gedacht aber es ist so hier
sind selbst Tannenbäume stylisch zwar
mega weihnachtlich aber immer gesponsert
von fendy
Gucci
boah
gesehen jetzt gehen wir richtig auf
Christmas hier oder
wie GU mal die ST das möchte ich für
unsere neue Wohnung haben da gibt schon
Christmas Vibes oder oh mein Herz lacht
wir brauchten ja noch einen roten Faden
für dieses Video und ich habe den roten
Faden gefunden zw wir bewerten Christmas
Deko von den
oh mein Gott das sind auch
chrisbaumkugeln oh nein
Timo
schöner oh mein Gott die Gläser sehen ja
schön aus und guck mal diese
Christbaumkugel wir gehen einmal rein
gib mir so richtig weihnachtliche we ja
das ist viel
schöner deine Mama wird den l gut finden
wir K
se kann ich noch eine K
kannst mitnehmen ich habe das Gefühl wir
sind hier in so einem richtigen myänder
Haus geraten guck mal wie weit das hoch
geht die
Treppen komplettes Treppenhaus no man
sieht sogar noch das Dach oder ich frag
den Weihnachtsmann lieber guter
Weihnachtsmann darf ich noch eine
kristbaumkugel haben ja aber sicher doch
danke Weihnachtsmann also wir müssen auf
jeden Fall unsere ursprüngliche Meinung
revidieren von wegen dass sie nicht so
mit London mithalten können die Straße
ist schon die können definitiv mit
London mithalten wir haben ja jetzt
gesagt wir bewerten Weihnachtsdeko aber
meinst du jetzt von von den Läden an
sich oder meinst du die
straßendeko von den Läden okay also Loro
Piana 9 von ze Bo eentlich schon eine ze
von ze ne findest du weiß ich nicht ich
find es schön ich find es imposant aber
es ist so nicht die ultimative geballte
Christmas Ladung in mein Gesicht gut
okay ich geb acht sagen alles klar was
kriegt Salvini von dir Vanessa wir
brauchen ein Mal richt WTE um hier das
Ranking überhaupt mal ne müssen die
Leisten erstmal markieren wo ist unten
wo ist oben was ist das für dich alles
klar also das da war eine neun das war
eine neun okay was haben wir hier
Salvini ja eine F F es ist hübsch die
hab sich schon Mühe gegeben ist schon
groß okay aber im Endeffekt ist es auch
einfach nur eine Gelande um die den
Eingangsbereich F finde ich auch glaube
ich gerecht ist das echte Tanne oh echte
Tanne gibt vi noch Punk extra o siehst
du
[Musik]
dorttiertieren
okay jetzt habe ich gar nicht kommen
sehen Alter ktier schon mal gut viele
Lichter anscheinend hat Italien nicht so
ein Stromproblem aber okay ze von ze ne
das ist eine Kare das ist eine 10 von
weil sehr svoll ist ist es ist sehr
symmetrisch aber auch doch verspielt mit
diesen goldenen glitzernden Wolken da
oben hast du ein Zeppelin das hat so
richtig den New York Christmas vi man
fühlt sich wie bei Kevin alleine in New
York und das ganze Haus wurde mit
eingearbeitet ich frage mich ob das
ganze Haus Quartier ist aber so wie es
aussieht ja es ist ein ganzes
quartierhaus es ist so schön ich kann
nicht mehr ze von ze und du ne geben
schon auch stilvoll aber ich find diese
wolkchen da überzeugen mich jetzt nicht
so wirklich muss ich sagen reien sogar
ein bisschen raus aus dem ganzen Konzept
nächstes gibt es Weihnachtsdeko von
Hermes aber auch wieder ganz anderer
Style ne ich liebe den Minimalismus ich
liebe es dass es ein bisschen aussieht
wie Zuckerguss auf einem Lebkuchenhaus
nicht viel Farbe das ist bei mir
natürlich immer ich mag ein bisschen rot
ein bisschen Grün ne die klassischen
Weihnachtsfarben aber doch sehr
geschmackvoll und wieder schön an das
Haus angelehnt also Sie dekorieren sehr
dem Haus entsprechend nach dem ktier ist
mein Anspruch sehr hoch gegangen
deswegen gibt's leider hier nur eine
acht von ze kann ich nur beipflichten
ich glaub wir sind beide auch so
bisschen New York Christmas Vibes Fans
oder was sagen wir dazu jaada geht
dieses Jahr in eine sehr moderne
Richtung ein verspieltes Bild fast schon
wie bei hermess aber einfach
herausbrechen aus den Konventionen und
die
[Musik]
moderne 7 von
ze
Christian Dior Schmetterlinge vermutet
man erstmal nicht zu Weihnachten dennoch
passt es gut rein aber ich bleibe dabei
Schmetterlinge kein Weihnachtsmotiv mir
fehlt ein bisschen die Symmetrie bei den
Schaufenstern du hast da rund eckig dann
ist es nicht dekoriert also ich würde
sagen eine gute neun von ze wir sind ja
hier gerade so am bewerten und dann
laufe ich an diesem Laden
vorbei
das sind Kunstwerke
[Musik]
wirklich ist einfach eine Torte oh mein
Gott Timo wir müssen einmal reingehen
Timo lass uns bitte einmal
[Musik]
reingehen was ist den das
da ist so
ein
got
alle Espresso stand gerade alleur kurz
Espresso zwischen den rein
und
Espresso ja dann hol vielleicht gib auch
ein
Espresso do you have Dec Espresso
dann oh ich habe den Preis erst danach
gesehen nachdem ich den Cookie
ausgesucht
habe ich habe dir leider nicht gesagt
was der Cookie gekostet
hat habe ich erst
danach guck das an ket€
Leute
[Musik]
gessen der Kaffee
gemacht und
schmeckton
schokoladeol simpel doch in der
simpelheit steckt auch etwas es gibt ein
krasses Farbenspiel mit den
Lichterketten
trotzdem ein bisschen wenig da wä noch
ein bisschen mehr gegangen vi von ze ne
ja D von ze einmal zum Baumark Gefahren
l wir laufen hier gerade random diese
Straße entlang sehen erstmal diesen
krassen Torbogen und da hinten ist der
Endgegner der Tannenbäume let's
go weiß nicht ob man auf der Kamera da
hinten schon sieht aber er sieht huge
aus du lebst ein in dieser Stadt und ich
glaube das ist der erste Baum der nicht
sponsert von irgendeinem modemark ist oh
ja kein Sponsoring ah obwohl gleich
dieser Tannenbaum ist nicht
gesponsert jeder andere tannbaum ist
gesponser wow
Timo ich habe einen neuen Lebenstraum
und das wird unser
Tannenbaum wir pflanzen dieses Jahr ein
und irgendwann ist er so
groß deutsche gavana überzeugt hier mit
einem übertriebenen maximalismus
deutsche gana 10
[Musik]
von
ze von ze und unsere kleine stadtour
endet mit dem wirklich größten
Weihnachtsbaum der Welt mein Gewinner
heute ist katier das hat einfach alles
ein bisschen modern bisschen klassisch
sehr weihnachtlich ze von ze aber man
muss sagen alle Läden sind wirklich echt
krass also gerade die luxusmark
natürlich krass im dekorieren und es gab
hier einfach richtig viel zu gucken und
als letztes gibt's den größten
Weihnachtsbaum der Welt zu gucken und
wir suchen jetzt ein
Restaurant so wir sind jetzt im Hotel
und ich möchte diesen Keks probieren der
15 € Keks timo hat recht ich sollte ihn
essen und nicht aufbewahren weil sonst
habe ich gar nichts davon außer oh jetzt
doch ich ärger mich jetzt schon dass ich
die Packung aufgemacht habe boah machen
wir auch versuchen wir auch so schöne
Kekse zu machen so wie der Endlevel
schaffen wir nicht obwohl schaffen wir
können wir das
schaffen wir schaffen das nee h schon
erzählt dass nee ich werde den so
aufstellen ich meine der H der wird doch
schlecht der kann ja nicht schlecht
werden wie der kann nicht schlecht
werden na ja das ist ja nur Zucker und
so echt jetzt boah der riecht
fantastisch es komm echt ja klar Leben
des dens zu
genießen
m ich fühle mich schlecht aber sehr gut
sehr sehr sehr gut ich mach
symmetrisch ja und eine Sache wollte ich
auch noch erzählen kurz vom Schlafen
gehen wir wollten eigentlich so ein
bisschen mehr im Restaurant filmen was
wir dort essen aber wir haben das erste
mal miterlebt dass ein Mensch
notärztliche Hilfe braucht während er
quasi im Restaurant ist das war so ganz
komisch weil wir haben schon gemerkt die
Kellner einen Gast ganze Zeit beobachtet
haben schon so mit so besorgten Augen
und irgendwie hatten wir nicht ganz
gecheckt warum wir dachten erst
irgendwie der Macht Stress oder
vielleicht ist es irgendwie keine Ahnung
man konnte es einfach nicht gut checken
und dann hat halt Timo gesehen wie der
so immer mehr zusammengesackt ist und
wir wissen nicht ob er ein Schlaganfall
hatte oder einfach nur ein
Kreislaufzusammenbruch auf jeden Fall
war er dann da ganz lange bis dann dre
Notärzte kam und dann kamen noch zwei
andere der wurde dann rausgetragen
irgendwann oder rausgerollt mit so einem
Rollstuhl und es war so absurd weil
einem die Situation so leid tat und man
so schockiert davon war dass es halt
überhaupt gerade passiert aber
gleichzeitig wolltest du ja nicht
disrespectful sein und da irgendwie
jetzt hinstarren oder aufhören zu essen
und dann saß man da so und hat dann
irgendwie weiter gegessen und das so ein
bisschen weg ignorieren wollen oder so
ein bisschen überspielen wollen aber es
war wirklich die absurdeste Situation in
der wir seit langem waren oder aber ich
muss sagen die anderen also ich fand ich
war überrascht davon dass dann doch so
wenig Gäste irgendwie da so hingestarrt
haben ich hätte gedacht dass wenn sowas
in so einem Restaurant passiert das
warmer früher so eine Angst vor mir die
Franzosen haben do sogar aufgestanden
hast du gesagt ja ja außer die Franzosen
war so eine Gruppe von vier Franzosen
die die
für die war das ein großes happening
aber der Rest hat man gemerkt dass war
so sehr respektvoll was so eine
irgendwie so eine absurde Angst von mir
auch wegnimmt die ich immer hatte früher
wenn ich dachte so scheiße wenn ich
jetzt hier irgendwie wenn der Notar
wegen mir kommen muss und so dann ist
der ganze Laden quasi dann mache ich
alles kaputt hier aber nein tatsächlich
kannst du mitten im Restaurant irgendwas
haben das noter zuuk kommen und alle
anderen tun so als ob nichts wer machen
weiter muss man ja irgendwie aber ja
nee ganz ganz weird muss auch sagen
haben super reagiert die Waren sofort Z
zur Stelle und so ja stimmt die K die
anderen da daneben saßen und jeder hat
einfach weiter gegessen und ignoriert
sonder das war so nein nein nein es war
auch schon natürlich hat man es im Raum
gemerkt aber es war dann schnell klar
dass dann quasi notalz gerufen wurde und
da jemand bei ihm war und so aber es war
jetzt nicht so dass alle aufgehört haben
zu essen und ihn angeguckt haben und da
irgendwie quasi ganze Restaurant einmal
kurz die Zeit stehen geblieben ist
sondern ja irgendwie ging es dann
wirklich weiter so viel
dazu bis morgen Leute
war deine gute Nachtgeschichte oder wie
das war die